this is such an amazing honor i'm so  grateful to academy gold for this  incredible recognition  i had an amazing team that made this  project possible  um thank you to my producer christine  chope for being my partner through the  trenches um thank you to my key creators  sherry kian much tawa mishikari andrei  lin and valdemar kuzia  thank you to my chapman university  professors andy lane thomas harris  michael kowalski roy finch rachel  goldberg and to taylor braun  thank you to  henrietta defilius and the faculty at  after film school in johannesburg  thank you to my incredible cast the  connor bali  and thank you to our producing mentors  dylan worked marcel de toit  ramadan suleiman  and to our incredibly generous donors  and thank you to my mom for inspiring me  to pursue my dreams thank you